After this, we'll travel from the base camp of the Witch's Lament to the home of the
white horse's tail serpent
and the palm of the troll, and first we'll
aim for this Andis colony.
So here's Jolly Jolly, so
the next one is bad Jolly Did
you look carefully? You
can read the map
There's no route like that There's a
bridge Uh,
look
, that's the famous place that's our final destination That's
why  Jolly Jolly,
do you understand? I'm not good at explaining.
I've been running around as much as I want since I
was a kid, but I've always come back.
I'm doing
it 1 Nasca
here it
's here Marker travels believing in his
own
here
.
I'm going to the scene after the nome I've been skipping the marker all this time
I'm going to my
destination